how do i start the video leave your
entries in the subreddit
and i'll watch submissions in the next
episode
welcome to the why everyone everyone's
favorite
show let's just jump in of course the
number one thing this week
brad bye bye everyone say bye bye brad
has left the channel
this is so sad but the videos must still
continue
time you are now brad one no that is
you are finally side one congratulations
[Music]
all the best and good luck to brad whoa
that is amazing
that's giving me serious uh shadow of
the colossus vibes
i really want to build another meatball
you ever have that feeling when you're
like i want to build another meatball
right now right now i want to build
another meatball
so this is made by mask man insane and
that kids
is how i met your mother now
don't wait i mean they did do it i
realized
the one that went into the other cage is
most likely
so tiny that it could escape and then he
went to the other cage and then he grew
up in there
it all makes sense they freak they freak
okay
yeah yeah this is the plane that we have
on the minecraft series i have the
trident actually that was a spoiler oh
god oh
i have the channeling it's about to go
down and it's going to be sweet in case
you don't know
we're going to freak the wither with
pigment what am i talking about
i'm trying to unravel this video as if
you've never seen my channel before and
i realized this is absolutely impossible
the amount of lore the unmounted no you
need to understand pewdiepie
marzia wow you're up nice early felix
knowing damn well he's been up all night
i would if i could okay i'm literally
shooting this video early
same thing last week everyone's like you
look so tired i'm like yeah it's so i
can play minecraft
you don't understand hey where's when by
the way getting flashbacks here
i don't understand your memes how am i
supposed to understand this
the original the critically acclaimed
sequel
the under appreciated revision the
failed live action
the controversial spin-off the fanfic
that went too far
oh it's gone too far it's definitely
gone too far at this point
hi sven looking forward to becoming
friends oh no
run runway is still at the chat
this is so mean do you think i want to
live like this all alone
and no one loves me everyone dead hey
you going to sleep
yes now [ __ ] what if marcia inhaled a
helium balloon
upcoming video idea question mark i
think she's done it we've done it in a
video
markiplier didn't want to play undertale
because people harassed him for playing
it the wrong
way don't do this with felix and his
minecraft series let him play how he
wants to play
i'm pretty sure we've established this
but i do appreciate it
now frank i think that's what made the
series so fun people just wanted to help
out instead of being like oh
you idiot why you do it wrong am i
really going to defile this grape for
money i needed the money
i'll build ornaments okay it all evens
out
it all evens out nobody pictures in
every barbershop
how do you guys find this
that's a dope photos though like that
was that's pretty cool
peace and tranquility until
i love this sound of fan art let's just
show how
dumb the whole thing is wouldn't it be
amazing no it wouldn't have been amazing
it would have been
horrible and sad but wouldn't have been
amazing if i actually killed it
i found you felix you have your trident
in your second house
no i don't i lost it in the water temple
the first time i went in i was like i'll
bring my trident that would be cool
right
i died i lost it we don't have to talk
about it
it doesn't matter okay at least i'm
being honest instead of just being like
oh i'll just spawn that in okay so
appreciate honesty hello
the last thing a villager sees
before gets kidnapped
get in the boat oh my god you guys might
say told me how annoying it was
that she posted her photo and everyone
just made pewdiepie references and i was
like yeah that is really annoying and
then i read the comments
get in the box marcia searching for
denim and i'm like that's actually funny
mars is like
wedding over felix when you're tending
to your farm and some swedish man
starts walking
when you're tending to your farm and
some swedish guy starts complimenting
your crops
and whips out a boat from his back
pocket
no matter how far you've come never
forget your route i saw this
someone someone did like fixing or
improving
which is not fair i will never be able
to build like this come on
i do love the atlas shrug the statue
that's really dope
how jurgen one and two died so sad by
the way how bernie died
like a goddamn hero never forget
what bernie did for your country nobody
shampoo advertisement
damn she must use a lot of that bamboo
pee pee poopoo
has observed pewter from the very
beginning
he's been there since number one before
jurgen
before sweden there's a common fan
theory right now that
people is whoever holds the saddle no
one pewdiepie when he sees minecraft
i understand that reference i know where
this is coming from
how long can we push minecraft until it
becomes cringy again
i'm just curious villager taking photo
after being kidnapped see i saw this and
that's when
when uh that's when bride went bye bye i
was like this is the picture
armed robber wore minecraft costume
police space
dude at the counter oh man
oh man and then he started flossing
creeper
oh man this is what went down and then
ali a came in out of nowhere it was epic
it was crazy
pewdiepie cheating other people cheating
cheating for a really cool base full of
immense riches
cheating to feed pee purple army the
meatball is real
get it in your thick skulls petition to
have pewdiepie put a dutch flag
in the nether to make it netherlands
that's genius
that is the smartest thing i've ever
heard what is wrong with nether what is
wrong with dutch people
why are you her country like this i am
inevitable
and i am straight damn that's badass
loki this kinda makes me wanna bring
sven to the fight against the wither
throw spanish sword here's van gogh but
i know how
to use i saw you in anime you did it
2014 nah i don't believe in gods or
anything
2019 pewdiepie oh almighty watersheep
give us guidance give us hope show us
the way watersheep
accept humble offering minecraft truly
has
made me a believer again it's getting
pretty dark down here
hello i left him for half an episode oh
no he's died
this makes it so much sadder f's in the
chat boys
at least he died for a good cause
adventure is out there
jack told me yesterday he's like felix i
have to tell you something
you can put dog in boat and then you can
make horse go after i'm like
really you think i don't know the
sven do something bark incredible what
i don't know if it ever got posted here
but adventure time predicted watersheep
my god
my god he exists in every universe every
realm
there is a watershed felix when you turn
the
poop or arm into zombie man make sure
sven is sitting if he's not then he will
try and attack pigmen
that you struck with lightning the
pigment will kill him keeps them
safe that's not sven why you waste my
time they built some assassins
an army of 60 million subscribers
an army of nine-year-olds an
army of people and i got so many
comments about people from like
dude such a childish name bro grow up
are you actually nine i'm like
yeah yeah yeah it's not ironic humor
okay
just because you don't have the big
brains to understand ironic humor
and don't try to criticize me and the
boys raiding area 51
me and the boys coming back
damn what the sheep look hella freaky
if you ask me ed i'd ask if he's single
side when people
still call him brad too after brad
stopped editing for beards
say scythe right now such a good meme
side don't cut this out oh that's right
now you can't blame brad if anything
gets cut out anymore
ah now it hurts how can i enjoy the wine
now
if i can't complain to bread here it is
pee pee poo poo
is not a name it's a title given to the
most distinguished
swine that is destined to lead the army
walking dead i killed 14 characters game
of thrones well i killed
37 characters amateurs
i like the cloak as well amateurs
all my friends i kill in two weeks pugs
will hit 99
for 20 69 6 subscribers i don't know if
that's true
but i'm too lazy to check so that's
awesome
hey guys 12 hour minecraft live stream
at 100 million
let's get it go subscribe god damn it
tell your friends and family
kids from the future here guys check out
my stream deck
xlgarde can you see it it's actually
really useful
now that i edit some of my own videos i
can put commands and open different apps
just by clicking buttons blink blink
blink open uh
edit block you see that you see screen
change open photoshop
flip plot it's really cool i definitely
recommend check it out you can use it as
sound boards and all that kind of stuff
on with video link description bye
page subreddit will become the biggest
subreddit in 2021
i don't know if that's true but i'm too
lazy to check
i like that mean template that's good
pewdiepie you're a diamond so i don't
have time to read
i get i'm kidding all right i appreciate
it thank you again
seriously i get the joke
especially when you get the lapis you're
like blue blue
is there some kind of automatic fish
farm i can make this entire sub
come on well then tell me choose your
super power
flight invisibility fast
control water cloning
that's his ability it all makes sense
while t-series wanting subs felix
wanting relevancy
it's probably just because you're
subscribed and you know it doesn't
matter
sure sure whoa that's a strong cat
sorry mr cat i still don't have a cat in
minecraft i wake up in the middle of the
night
marcia comes over are you okay felix i
still don't have cat in minecraft
felix you need three babies so that baby
has bed too
before you get a third bait they won't
frick oh they fricked
you just gotta throw fruits and
vegetables at them they will frick
i know you guys are nine and you want to
try and tell me these stuff like i don't
know
how to frick okay throw vegetables get a
bed put some nice lighting
and they will frick everyone freaky
smoky i can say frick as many times as i
want freaky leaky picky
youtube what are you gonna do i found
the loophole in system
freak freak freak freak i hold the power
now i bet if we all said frick enough
that would be the new f word when people
realize they can't blame
their less what
can your minecraft chair do this
why have i not built this all right i'm
writing that down
i'm writing that down for my minecraft
let's play see i saw this and it was
actually really helpful i appreciate it
so billy ellis music published sure just
took 100
revenue from my cover video it features
no part of the original recording on
spotify they would only be able to take
about 25
of the revenue youtube has made awful
deals giving the industry
music industry all the power thank you
well put
joel oh you made this 10 minute original
content video
oh i'm sorry we own half a second of
that money
give me money mine don't let pewds
forget that he has to marry martin this
year instead of getting addicted to
minecraft oh i'm well aware
it's really hard already keeping up with
everything i have an idea
for felix watershed wall that is so cool
so is that just pistons pushing it
through oh yeah
that doesn't look too complicated either
huh i can build that
yeah yeah that's so cool
i think the only problem is uh it's
gonna be quite loud isn't it
having pistols going constantly periods
can't wait to show your
oh
we have dark jargon now that's right
that's his name did felix forget his
second house near the iceberg
yeah it's ugly okay let it burn no
so he did it again
are we not gonna talk about the irony of
the fact that i killed peepee poopoo
with what i was trying to heal him with
isn't there some bittersweet
harmony there pee pee poo poo ender
dragon
high effort meme took me five seconds
damn
episode one he's come so far i can't
write pig are you
kidding me join us fellow peepee rolf
my best friend throughout the whole
playthrough say sack right now
i just realized anytime i say my best
friend my best friend dies
and sven is supposed to be my best
friend and he not die
sven kill everyone it's just a theory
pewdiepie and ken making a cobblestone
generator for three video street i'm
sorry
i'm sorry for taking so long it's it's
not yeah it's sure it's big brain time
feelings playing alone phillips playing
with jack
phillips
[Music]
oh yeah i saw this in the comments i've
used it already thank you
it's actually really helpful oh man
damn that's epic during the winter
battle felix is going to accidentally
hit a zombie pigman and they will all
try
this can't happen they are loyal to me i
birthed
them i birthed them they loyal god you
guys make me cringe
pewdiepie should get an orange cat in
minecraft like his old cat
schnitzel where did schnitzel come from
his name was gustav because gustav means
garfield in swedish and he was orange
and he was also very fat and we also
didn't like him so no
no thank you how do you know about my
old cat huh how do you know
can you make them fat like that cause
then i want them if i can make them fat
i want them
you could seriously hurt yourself son
please push me to the edge
all friends equals dead i have to change
the lyrics otherwise this
video gets copyrighted thank you youtube
the system is working
perfect oh my god
what if sven is killing everybody to be
alone with pits forever this is
literally what i said
our thoughts are like so synced today
mark says engagement ring
how do you guys know how do you guys
find all this stuff when your name is
the same as felix dog
it's free karma sven upvote
saving dinner bone from the bottom of
the ocean or
saving dinner bone from felix by hiding
him
come on he's safe now he's been safe at
least an episode and that's longer than
most people
this game is so anime
damn
[Applause]
oh my god
that's so cool
whoa
that is not how we went down but yeah
that's awesome
that's so cool
yes dark yard again everyone
that's so cute that's awesome you can't
defeat me
i know but he can oh
[Music]
this is so sad 20 43 31
17 4142
uh it is a lot of work and i i
appreciate you guys
appreciating the extra time that was a
sentence apparently not only is there an
ikea fish but there's also
pewdiepie what give
give it felix i did some redstone off
camera
damn what is that it's like people
building computers in minecraft
i read this book called the three body
problem
they make a computer out of people like
an army of people just by making
them follow certain commands and all
these always make me think of minecraft
how you can just make a computer
literally out of anything that can
listen to simple
see i don't know how a computer works
okay i just think it's cool that you can
actually do that
according to imdb peer news is the 48th
best
show of all time
top 10 let's go baby top 10.
there it is thanks guys i really really
appreciate it
oh that's so cute you felt bad for them
youtube trending again seriously you
can't stop minecraft youtube
i fear no man with that thing it's gays
you should be afraid we're coming for
you winter whether you like it or not
sved survives 11 creeper explosions
felix
uses two totems someone dying while
building
oh there's another one oh
i'm sorry ikea bird
you can't put a name tag on slimes and
they won't d-spot edit
never mind he died why
join us roll roll
can we appreciate how generally happy is
how much he accomplished in today's
episode
i did redstone and make me happy when
redstone works because they make me
angry when it doesn't
fame power fat bank can't change
everyone all pet dead
this is sad sven you're the new dj
sven all right gamers thanks for
watching another episode of
thanks for all the support thanks for
checking out the merch everything you do
has been amazing
ever since i played minecraft i've been
generally having so much fun
and i hope you had it as well i want to
finish this off by playing a song
by part in the backyard this will be the
outro of this video
thank you guys for watching as always
see you next time
[Music]
is
when you're far away from
[Music]
your um baby
spell
what